governor tell us
why someone who is already facing huge
cost of living pressures around energy
bills now has to face increases to their
borrowing costs on top it's a very
important question it's probably the
most important question i realize the
distress because it is a very difficult
situation to both have such a large
increase in inflation
and to be forecasting that the will bomb
threat be a recession and to be saying
we have to increase and to increase uh
interest rates
and the reason is this we've had this
very big huge external shock uh you know
in the three months since we last did
the monetary policy report i mean the
change to the
you know the whole energy price
particularly gas price uh regime has
been massive and i'm afraid that has to
be put at the door of russia there's no
question about that now
very reasonable to ask the question so
why are you raising interest rates in
that context because you can see that
yes inflation's going to get very high
but you know other things equal
it ought to come down again and we do
project that actually
the worry for us is are other things
going to be equal and the the really
difficult situation this is why i'm
afraid we have to do it is
if we have more persistent inflation
that is harder for everybody we'll have
to raise rates by more
and and those you know people and
particularly those on low incomes will
be even more affected and that's the
thing that concerns me so is it the case
this has got to hurt if it's going to
work the reason we're doing it is
because if we don't get
the inflation under control if we don't
bring it down from where i'm afraid it's
got to go up to because of the say of
this huge energy
shock that we're having
if we don't bring it down
then then the damage and the distress
will be even greater
the main pressure is external
gas prices
everyone understands that
is it really the case that you need to
tighten the screw at home is that
judgment are you sure about that
judgment
you're right that the main pressure is
external and that's going to feed
through into inflation i'm afraid over
this winter we do think it's going to
come down you know going through next
year and
beyond
but we have got another thing going on
which is domestic the size of the labor
force has shrunk there are fewer people
you know working in the economy
and that's affecting uh you know when i
go around the country a lot of spend a
lot of time going around the country the
first thing that every firm wants to
talk to me about is i can't hire enough
people
and yeah we've got a situation where
we're saying well i think you know we
can already see the economy slowing it's
going to get worse i'm afraid and yet
firms are saying
two things to me one is they're still
able to increase prices and they're not
getting resistance and they just can't
hire enough people and of course that
does have an upward effect on uh
on costs and you've talked about wages
in the past somewhat controversially in
the context of these inflation numbers i
mean above 10 percent well into next
year it's really reasonable to ask
people to accept
rises you know below 5
if everybody tries to get ahead of
inflation and we get inflation more
embedded we'll get more persistent
inflation
and that's why i said particularly you
know if you seek a high if you seek to
beat inflation
it will get into an upward you know
trend and we will have to we will have
to raise interest rates even more then
and that will be more painful okay um
much noise politically we have a contest
to become prime minister and you don't
want to get directly involved but there
are
questions about changing the mandate of
the bank and
some blame around liz trust certainly
her campaign
at the bank's door for this is this the
time to be
addressing the work you do here or is
that risk making a difficult situation
even worse well i i
i'm not going to get involved in the
campaign and the leadership election to
be leader of the conservative party the
next prime minister it's what i would
emphasize is that i think central bank
independence is an absolutely key part
of the economic system this country and
in other countries
it's it's an important part and
never more than now
this is the biggest test of our system
in the quarter of a century that it's
existed for last one if i may you talked
about a judgment called walking this
walking this path
consequences on either side
of getting it wrong more have you
thought about the consequences if you
have you and your colleagues have got
this wrong
we don't look at it from the point of
saying you know personally what if we
get it wrong this is about for the
country and for the economy so we spend
a lot of time looking at those risks and
you're confident you've got it right
we think this is
undoubtedly the right thing to do but we
will be back in you know about six weeks
time because that's the next monetary
policy committee meeting and we will
have to go all through the evidence
again there'll be new evidence and we
will do that all over again